[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
Кривопільський перевал]
Монах — це слово таке, ну...
По-справжньому це можна пояснити так:
той хто вийшов з дому,
щоб шукати справжній шлях.
От ти вийшов з дому,
в тебе дому немає, в тебе нічого немає.
Ти повинен весь час, кожного дня
практикувати цей шлях.
Думати не про свою сім'ю або про роботу,
а зовсім про інше.
Повинен вирощувати в собі великі думки.
Я буддійський монах нашої громади,
яка так і називається:
Ніппондзан Мьоходзі
(«орден Лотосової сутри»).
Кожний вечір і світанок.
Це наша щоденна практика.
Ми називаємо цей процес таким словом:
«практика».
Медитація, практика.
Це практика Лотосової Сутри.
«Сутра» — це вчення Будди.
Це вчення. Воно не для самовдосконалення.
Чи досягнення якихось ступенів. Ні.
Воно існує для порятунку інших людей,
світу, країни.
Тоді був особливий час.
Перебудова, якийсь вітер приніс зміни. Дуже сильні.
Я думав: як жити і чому присвятити своє життя?
Те, що я бачив навкруги,
мене не задовольняло.
Наша громада є найстарішою
буддійською громадою в Україні.
Перша.
Була зареєстрована 9 вересня 1991 року.
Спочатку ми були вимушені виїхати
з Донецької і Луганської областей.
Утікати від війни.
Туди прийшли ці, як їх називають, ополченці.
[Сергій Філоненко
Буддистський монах]
Тому ми залишили в Донецьку
і в Луганській області наші місця.
Ми довго шукали по всіх Карпатах
майже три роки.
Переглянули багато різних ділянок,
але щось нас не задовольняло.
Потім, коли ми поверталися
через Кривопільський перевал,
такий великий олень перебіг нам дорогу.
Сенсей сказав, що це знак,
що сам дух лісу показує нам місце.
Ми почали шукати і, врешті-решт, знайшли.
Тут була стара хата,
але її не вдалося зберегти.
Ми побудували нову.
Великої різниці не бачу: Донецьк чи тут.
Але тут деякі місцеві сприймають це
і розуміють, що це молитва.
Ви знаєте, справжні українці — це Мамаї.
Кожен українець — це козак Мамай.
Оце і є справжній характер українців.
Нам потрібні ці Мамаї,
щоб вони пробудилися в кожному з нас.
Цей дух вільного,
чесного,
справжнього і дуже відкритого серця.
Ми повинні знайти до цього шлях.
Я хотів би, щоб наш український народ
був більш об'єднаний.
Такий, щоб він знав, як будувати Україну.
Тому що наші люди ще не знають, як це робити.
Мені так здається.
Щоб якась глибина відкрилася.
Я відчуваю, що в нашій країні
є дуже глибоке коріння.
Кожен може розвиватися
і допомагати іншим.
У середині кожного є серце.
Хто такий «я»?
Цього «я» не існує.
«Я» — це всі ці полонини,
зірки — все це ми.
Насправді.
Проте сказати так дуже легко,
а реалізувати в собі — це зовсім інша справа.
Це називається «шлях».
Завдяки цій практиці я можу багато що змінити.
Це просто віра.
Я вірю в те, що можу змінити світ.
Якщо я буду далі іти шляхом практики
і дійсно розвивати таку свідомість,
то я зможу змінити цей світ.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Ліза Литвиненко]
[Музика
OY Sound System, Dakha Brakha]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]